مساء الخير؛
يقول في كتابه ترجمان الأشواق؛
لقد كنت قبل اليوم أنكر صاحبي..
اذا لم يكن ديني إلى دينه داني..
قد صارَ قلـبي قابلاً كلَ صُـورةٍ ..
فـمرعىً لغـــــزلانٍ ودَيرٌ لرُهبـَــــانِ..
وبيتٌ لأوثــانٍ وكعـــبةُ طـائـــفٍ ..
وألـواحُ تـوراةٍ ومصـحفُ قــــــرآن..
أديـنُ بدينِ الحــــبِ أنّى توجّـهـتْ ركـائـبهُ،
فالحبُّ ديـني وإيـمَاني..
لنا أُسْوَة ٌ في بِشْرِ هندٍ وأُخْتِهَا..
وقيسٍ وليلى، ثمَّ مي وغيلانِ..
هو،
محمد بن علي بن محمد بن عربي الحاتمي الطائي الأندلسي،
المعروف بمحيي الدين بن عربي،
له عدة القاب،
أهمها؛
الشيخ الأكبر،
والكبريت الأحمر،
ورئيس المكاشفين،
والبحر الزاخر،
وبحر الحقائق،
وإمام المحققين،
وسلطان العارفين،
وابن أفلاطون،
وتلميذ الخضر.
كتب ابن عربي أكثر من 800 كتاب ورسالة،
لكن لم يبق منها سوى 100 مؤلف من أهمّها؛
كتاب الفتوحات المكية، المُكَوّن من 37 مجلّد و560 باب،
وكتاب فصوص الحكم،
و ديوان ترجمان الاشواق،
وكتاب شجرة الكون،
وكتاب اليقين...
ولد محيي الدين إبن عربي في مدينة مُرسية في الأندلس،
في 17 أو 27 من شهر رمضان سنة 560 هـجرية،
الموافق للسابع والعشرين من يوليو سنة 1165 ميلادية.
تنتمي أسرته إلى قبيلة طيء العربية، التي ينحدر منها حاتم الطائي،
العربي المسيحي، وهو من  أشهر كرماء العرب.
بدأ  محيي الدين ابن عربي يتحسس طريقه
نحو العالم الروحاني منذ نعومة أظفاره،
ينقل لنا المستشرق الفرنسي هنري كوربان
في كتابه "الخيال الخلاّق في تصوّف ابن عربي"،
قصة مرض ابن عربي كما رواها هذا الأخير بنفسه،
فيقول هنري كوربان :
«في هذه الفترة بالتحديد بدَت على ابن عربي علامات القدرة الاستشراقيّة.
وقد ألمَّ به المرض وأدخلته الحمّى في حالة سبات وفتور عميقين.
وخاله أهله ميتاً،
فيما كان هو في عالمِه الباطني
يرى نفسه محاطاً بمجموعة من الشخصيات الخطيرة ذات المظهر الجهنمي.
لكن، ظهر فجأة شخص ذو جمال رباني مضمخ بعطر عذب الرائحة،
فقهر بقوته الجبارة الكائنات الشيطانية.
فسأله: من أنت؟
فأجاب: أنا سورة (يس).
والحقيقة أن أباه المسكين القلق على حياة ابنه كان يتلو سورة (يس)
بتلاوة خاصة بمن أتتهم سكرات الموت....»
ويعتبر هنري كوربان أن ذلك كان أول دخول لابن عربي في اتصال مباشر بعالم المثال.
سورة (يس) سوف يجعلها في ما بعد محيي الدين بن عربي "قلب كتاب الله"...
الولادة الروحية لمحيي الدين بن عربي كانت مؤنثة،
لذلك سوف نرى ان للمرأة خاصة وللأنثى عموما
مكانة مركزية في مشروعه الفكري.
تتلمذ ابن عربي عندما كان صبيا
على يد امرأةً من أشهر العارفات بإشبيلية،
وهي فاطمة بنت ابن المثنى القرطبي؛
يقول فى كتابه  الفتوحات المكيّة متحدّثا عنها":
" وخدمت أنا بنفسي امرأة من المحبات العارفات بإشبيلية
يقال لها فاطمة بنت ابن المثنى القرطبي،
خدمتها سنين،
وهي تزيد في وقت خدمتي إياها على خمس وتسعين سنة،
وكنت أستحي أن أنظر إلى وجهها وهي في هذا السن
من حمرة خديها وحسن نعمتها وجمالها،
تحسبها بنت أربع عشرة سنة من نعمتها ولطافتها،
وكان لها حال مع الله،
وكانت تؤثرني على كل من يخدمها من أمثالي،
وتقول ما رأيت مثل فلان،
إذا دخل علي دخل بكله لا يترك منه خارجا عني شيئا،
وإذا خرج من عندي خرج بكله لا يترك عندي منه شيئا.
ويضيف ابن عربي؛
"فما زلت أخدمها بنفسي،
وبنيت لها بيتا من قصب بيدي على قدر قامتها فما زالت فيه حتى درجت،
وكانت تقول لي أنا أمك الإلهية ونور هي أمك الترابية،
(نور هي والدة ابن عربي)،
وإذا جاءت والدتي إلى زيارتها تقول لها يا نور؛
هذا ولدي وهو أبوك فبريه ولا تعقيه.
ابن عربي، رغم انه تتلمذ على يد رجال عارفين آخرين،
منهم الشيخ أبو العباس العُرَيْني،
والشيخ يوسف الكرمي،
والشيخ  التونسي عبد العزيز المهدوي،
الذي خصّه برسالة  "روح القدس في مناصحة النّفس"،
لكنّه لم يعترف لأي رجل من هؤلاء العارفين بالأبوّة الروحية،
وحدها فاطمة بنت ابن المثنى القرطبي اعتبرها أما روحيّة له.
محيي الدين بن عربي سيقرّ مبكّرا  بالأهلية الروحية للمرأة،
وحقّها في مراتب الولاية التي كانت حكرا على الذكور.
كرامات هذا المتصوّف اليافع في بلاد الأندلس،
سوف تصل إلى مسامع فيلسوف قرطبة أبي الوليد بن رشد،
الذي سيطلب من والد محيي الدين بن عربي
الذي كان صديقا له أن يلتقي بابنه؛
يتحدث ابن العربي عن هذا اللقاء في كتابه الفتوحات المكية فيقول:
"دخلت يوما بقرطبة على قاضيها أبي الوليد بن رشد،
وكان يرغب في لقائي لما سمعه،
وبلغه ما فتح الله علي في خلوتي...
وأنا صبي ما بقل وجهي ولا طَرّ شاربي.
فعندما دخلت عليه قام من مكانه إليّ محبة وإعظاما،
فعانقني وقال لي نعم،
فقلت له نعم.
فزاد فرحه بي لفهمي عنه،
ثم إني استشعرت بما أفرحه من ذلك،
فقلت له: لا؛
فانقبض وتغير لونه وشك فيما عنده، وقال:
كيف وجدتم الأمر في الكشف والفيض الإلهي؟
هل هو ما أعطاه لنا النظر؟
قلت له: نعم ولا،
وبين نعم ولا، تطير الأرواح من موادها،
والأعناق من أجسادها.
فاصفرّ لونه،
واخذه الأَفْكل،
وقعد يحوقل،
وما عرف ما أشرت به إليه،
وهو عين المسألة التي ذكرها هذا القطب الإمام،
أعني مُداوي الكُلوم."
اللقاء بين الرجلين هو في الحقيقة لقاء بين مدرستين متناظرتين،
مدرسة النظر والعقل والتي يمثلها شارح ارسطو الأكبر ابن رشد،
ومدرسة الإشراق التي يمثلها محيي الدين بن عربي،
المستشرق الإسباني الشهير أسين بالاثيوس،
صاحب كتاب "ابن عربي، حياته ومذهبه"،
يُعيد أصول فلسفة الإشراق عند ابن عربي،
إلى الفيلسوف الأندلسي ابن مسرّة الجبلي،
الذي ولد سنة 883 ميلادية وتوفي سنة 913 ميلادية،
ويعتبره ابن عربي نفسه «من أخير أهل الطريقة»،
الفكر العربي الإسلامي وقتئذ كان بين قطبين معرفيين؛
القطب الأرسطي المشّائي واهم رموزه ابن رشد،
والقطب الإشراقي الأفلاطوني وخاصة الأفلوطيني منه
نسبة إلى الفيلسوف اليوناني أفلوطين،
وأهم رموزه ابن سينا والكندي والفرابي
وابن مسرة الجبلي وابن عربي والسهروردي...
ابن رشد الذي كان يهدف في فلسفته إلى التوفيق بين الدين والفلسفة،
بين أرسطو والإسلام،
وخاض حربا فكرية طاحنة ضد الفقهاء والمتصوفة،
كان من أهم رموزها في الطرف المقابل ابو حامد الغزالي،
الذي كان قد كتب في نقد الفلاسفة كتابه الشهير "تهافت الفلاسفة"،
وردّ عليه ابن رشد بكتاب تهافت التهافت،
أراد ابن رشد من خلال لقائه بمحيي الدين بن عربي
أن يأخذ اعترافًا من رجل من رجال الذوق والكشف،
بأن الحقيقة التي تهدف إليها الفلسفة،
هي بعينها الحقيقة التي يهدف إليها الدين،
وأن العقل والروح لكل منهما مسلكه الخاص،
ولكنهما يلتقيان في نهاية الطريق.
ولم يكن هذا الاجتماع فاصلًا بين بين ابن رشد وابن عربي ،
فطلب ابن رشد منه لقاء ثانيا؛
يقول محيي الدين بن عربي:
وطلب ابن رشد من أبي بعد هذا الاجتماع أن يلتقي بنا،
ليعرض ما عنده علينا،
لنرى هل هو يوافق أم يخالف،
فإنه كان من أرباب الفكر والنظر العقلي،
فشكر الله الذي كان في زمانٍ رأى فيه مَنْ دخل خلوته جاهلًا،
وخرج مثل هذا الخروج،
من غير درس ولا بحث،
ولا مطالعة ولا قراءة.
وقال:
«هذه حالة أثبتناها وما رأينا لها أربابًا؛
فالحمد لله الذي أنا في زمان فيه واحد من أربابها،
الفاتحين مغاليق أبوابها،
والحمد لله الذي خصني برؤيته.»
استمتعوا إلى الحوار الذي دار بين ابن رشد وابن عربي،
في مسلسل سوري حمل عنوان مقامات العشق،
للمخرج أحمد إبراهيم أحمد،
وإنتاج تلفزيون أبو ظبي،
ويتناول سيرة الشيخ الأكبر محيي الدين بن عربي،
كاتب السناريو كان وفيا لروح اللقاء بين الرجلين،
كما ذكره ابن عربي في كتابه الفتوحات المكية.
السلام على سيدي قاضي المدينة،
وعليكم السلام ورحمة الله وبركاته،
نعم...
كيف وجدتم الأمر في الفيض والكشف الإلهى ؟
هل هو ما أعطاه لنا النظر؟
نعم ولا؛
وبين نعم ولا تطير الأرواح من موادها والأعناق من أجسادها...
سبحان الله،
ولا حول ولا قوة الا بالله،
الكلوم المداوي،
قطب يدور عليه فلك العارفين من رجال أفذاذ،
وإمام يقوم به ملكه،
ومن العلوم فيه،علم الدهر الأول الذي عنه تكونت الدهور،
وعلم الكيمياء والفلك...
الشكر لله انني في زمان،
رايت فيه من دخل خلوته  جاهلا وخرج مثل هذا الخروج،
من غير درس ولا بحث ولا مطالعة ولا قراءة،
هذه حالة اثبتناها وما وجدنا لها اربابا،
والحمد لله باني في زمان،
فيه واحد من أربابها،
الفاتحين مغالق أبوابها...
والحمد لله ان خصني برؤيتك،
تعالى يا محيي الدين.. تعالى..
لكني أعيد عليك السؤال يا محيي الدين،
في مناهج المعرفة، بين الإيمان والكشف والفكر والمنطق، ألا يلتقيان؟
الطرق الموصلة إلى العلم بالله طريقان لا ثالث لهما،
ومن وحد الله بغير هذين الطريقين فهو مقلّل في توحيده؛
الأول طريق الكشف،
يجده الإنسان في نفسه،
لا يقبل معه شبهة،
ولا يقدر على دفعه،
ولا يعرف لذلك دليلا يستند اليه سوى ما يجده في نفسه،
الا ان بعضهم قد يعطي الدليل والمدلول في كشفه،
والثاني،
طريق الفكر و الاستدلال بالبرهان العقلي،
وهذا الطريق دون الطريق الأول،
فصاحب النظر في الدليل قد تدخل عليه الشبهة القادحة في دليله،
فيتكلف الكشف عنها والبحث عن وجه الحق في الأمر المطلوب،
وإذا سألتني عن رأيي في مجمل الأمر أقول،
أن تعرف الحق سبحانه من حيث ما أخبرك  به عن نفسه أنه عليه،
مع اعتمادك على ما اقتضاه البرهان الوجودي،
مما ينبغي أن يكون الحق عليه سبحانه من التنزيه والتقديس،
فتجمع بين العلم  الذي أعطاك الإيمان،
وبين العلم الذي اقتضاه الدليل العقلي.
إذن فإن تطلب الجمع بين الطريقين. العقل والإيمان؟
لا،
بل تاخذ كل طريقة على انفرادها،
فتجعل الإيمان بقلبك بما أعطاك من معرفة الله
بمنزلة البصر بحسّك بما أعطاك من معرفة ما تقتضيه الحقيقة،
ولا يجوز أن تصرف نظرك الفكري في ما أعطاك اياه الإيمان
فتحرم عين اليقين.
إن الله أوسع من ان يقيده ايمان عن عقل،
أو عقل عن ايمان.
أصبت،
للعقل نور،
وللإيمان نور،
فنور العقل يوصل إلى معرفة وجود الله،
وبنور الإيمان يعرف ذات الحق،
وللعقل حد وللإيمان حد،
فعلى حد العقل تجري أمور العقلاء من الخلق،
وعلى حد الإيمان تجري أمور أولياء الله،
والمعرفة تامة منحصرة بالعلم في سبعة أشياء،
العلم بالأسماء الإلهية
والعام بتجلي الحق في الأشياء
والعلم بخطاب الحق في الأمور
وعلم الكيمياء...
وما اقصده بالأسماء الإلهية،
الكريم...
رغم اختلافهما،
لم ينكر ابن رشد على محيي الدين بن عربي علومه الكشفية،
بل حمد الله الذي مَنَّ عليه،
فدخل الخلوة جاهلًا وخرج منها إمامًا مرشدًا.
في المقابل ظل محيي الدين بن عربي
متمسكا بأمل اقناع ابن رشد بالسير في مسلك المتصوفة الراشدين.
لكن اللقاء الثالث،
الذي ذكره ابن عربي في الفتوحات المكية،
كان فاصلا في علاقة الرجلين،
فتأهّب  ابن عربي إلى اللقاء، ولكن الله أراد غير ذلك،
يقول ابن عربي:
«ولكن قبل أن ألتقي به أراه الله  تعالى لي في منظر
قد ضُرب بينه وبيني حجاب رقيق،
فكنت أنظر إليه منه ولا يبصرني؛
فعلمتُ أنه غير مراد لما نحن عليه...»
في كتابه "هكذا تكلّم ابن عربي"،
يذهب المفكّر المصري نصر حامد ابو زيد
إلى اعتبار أن هذا اللقاء الثالث الذي تحدّث عنه ابن عربي
هو لقاء خيالي برزخي وليس واقعيا.
سيجعل فيه ابن عربي بينه وبين ابن رشد حجابا رقيقا،
وهذا الحجاب الرقيق هو الفيصل بين الفيلسوف والعارف،
بين البصر والبصيرة،
ففي حين كان ابن عربي يستطيع ببصيرته أن ينظر وراء الحجاب،
كان ابن رشد عاجزا بعقله ان يدرك ما وراء الحجاب.
عاصر ابن عربي المحنة التي عاشها ابن رشد في قرطبة سنة 1195 ميلادية،
حيث نفاه وصادر كتبه الخليفة الموحّدي أبو يوسف يعقوب الملقّب بالمنصور
نزولا عند رغبة الفقهاء،
ليضمن دعمهم له في حروبه ضد الملوك الكاثوليك.
لكنّه عفا عنه بعد سنوات،
وعاد إلى مدينة مرّاكش ليتوفّى فيها سنة 1198 ويدفن هناك،
ثمّ نُقل جثمانه بعد ثلاثة أشهر إلى مسقط رأسه،
ليدفن من جديد في روضة آبائه بقرطبة،
ابن عربي حضر مراسم نقل جثمان ابن رشد في مرّاكش،
وقال في الفتوحات المكية؛ ما يلي:
"فما اجتمعت به (اي ابن رشد) حتى درج،
وذلك سنة خمس وتسعين وخمسمائة بمدينة مراكش،
ونقل إلى قرطبة وبها قبره.
ولما جُعل التابوت الذي فيه جسده على الدابة،
جُعلت تآليفه تعادله من الجانب الآخر،
وأنا واقف ومعي الفقيه الأديب أبو الحسين محمد بن جبير كاتب السيد أبي سعيد،
وصاحبي أبو الحكم عمر و ابن السراج الناسخ،
فالتفت أبو الحكم إلينا وقال:
ألا تنظرون إلى من يعادل الإمام ابن رشد في مركوبه؟
هذا الإمام وهذه أعماله،
يعني تآليفه،
فقال له ابن جبير:
يا ولدي نعم ما نظرت،
لا فض فوك،
فقيدتها عندي موعظة وتذكرة،
رحم الله جميعهم وما بقي من تلك الجماعة غيري وقلنا في ذلك :
هذا الإمام وهذه أعماله *** يا ليت شعري! هل أتت آماله؟
مشهد رحيل جثمان ابن رشد وكتبه من مرّاكش إلى قرطبة،
من الجنوب إلى الشمال،
مشهد رمزي جدّا،
ويعتبر المفكر المصري نصر حامد ابو زيد
أن ابن عربي  قرأ العبرة في رحيل ابن رشد ورثاه في تساؤله، هل أتت آماله؟
وبالفعل تحققت آمال ابن رشد في شمال المتوسّط،
واحتفى الغرب المسيحي بأفكاره،
في حين سيقرر محيي الدين إبن عربي الرحيل عن الأندلس والمغرب الإسلامي
بحثا عن تحقيق آماله في المشرق الإسلامي.
اتوقّف عند هذا الحدّ،
لأعود إليكم في الحلقة القادمة،
للحديث عن اهم محطّات رحلة الشيخ الأكبر محيي الدين بن عربي
نحو المشرق،
وقصّة الحب الكبيرة التي عاشها في مكّة مع فتاة تسمّى، "النظام"،
وهي ابنة عالم الحديث والشيخ زاهر الدين ابن رستم الكيلاني،
قصّة حب،
سوف تفجّر ينابيع الإبداع عند محيي بن عربي
ليكتب لنا ديوان ترجمان الأشواق،
من أروع ما كتب في الأدب الإنساني حول الحبّ والعشق والغزل.
أشكركم جزيل الشكر على المتابعة،
دمتم بخير،
وإلى لقاء قريب،
على قناة أنا أفكّر إذن أنا موجود...